foreign
here today we are going to talk about the future
of the DCU DC Universe and how we believe it's
going to be the biggest year yet for the DC
Universe one that could finally rival the MCU
mark my words end of 2023 you will be agreeing
with Greg John how are you I am excited to talk
about this I'm doing well sir how are you doing
well doing well ladies and gentlemen Shazam that
like button if you can smash it do whatever
you got to do to do it so we're going to talk
about several things today and uh some several
things some several things those proper proper
wording in sentences we're gonna talk about
updates in the DCU upcoming movies updates on
James Gunn and Peter saffron taking over Black
Adam Shazam Henry Cavill updates there's always
a whole bunch to go through and it's all just
making me that much more excited for 2023 and
what the DC Universe has to offer so first
thing on the list we got to go over that is
for sure an indication of this could be like
their most financially successful year to date
is they do have four movies officially coming in
2023 we have Shazam 2 Fury of the Gods The Flash
movie Blue Beetle and Aquaman and the lost kingdom
and Aquaman one that already hit a billion dollars
so if there's one of these that they're looking
to possibly make a billion dollars it could be
Aquaman and the lost kingdom but that's that's
got to be at least a couple billion right there
you know what I mean that's a movie every quarter
I mean like the fortunate thing about the position
they're in now is that you know the superhero
movie Machine pumps out so many a year that they
can easily catch up in little time with all these
things which one are you most successful John I
want to see sholo maraduena as the Blue Beetle I
want something new and I'm excited to see what he
brings to that me The Flash movie Yes flash two
uh so yeah I mean we have confirmation of those
four movies coming out in conjunction with each
other and I wanted to point that out first because
what we have here is from CEO David zosloff
everyone's greatest hero right now give it up
let's do this I got a iffy emotional association
with the guy yeah I can't imagine why but I'm
excited about James going to Peter saffron to say
the least so there was recently an earnings call
and there's this quote that's been going around
I'll read it for you right now I've spent a lot
of time over the past few months with James and
Peter which I find interesting that he's saying
that because you know like it wasn't that long ago
when he took over and it seems like he's had this
kind of in development from the beginning talking
about our strategy and long-term plans for the
future of DC across TV animation and film they
have a powerful vision and blueprint that will
drive a more unified creative approach that will
allow us to enable to the full value of one of
the world's most iconic franchises they are hard
at work right now meaning that seems like that
10-year plan or whatever the heck it was at Davis
office season looks like they might actually have
something in the world they might have an actual
plan now of what they might want to do so when
thinking about this I was like okay we're looking
at the release dates of these four movies and now
when you have The Flash coming out in June a month
after that is usually Comic-Con and they can make
a big splash at sdcc too many Z's they can make
a big splash there with their announcements of
what they have upcoming with whatever the plan is
that's being formulated following the success of
their Multiverse movie The Flash and whatever
that does with creating timelines or whatever
mojomo comes down the road but bottom line is they
could do that or if they'd wait after Blue Beetle
but before Aquaman the lost kingdom usually that
time in October is when they would have the DC
fandom where they can make an even bigger Splash
right then and there maybe they might even show up
at sdcc and DC fandom but if they have this plan
that they put into fruition because they'd have
to work with these four films I think right then
and there you know because when you think about
the idea of these four movies coming out four
movies that are more than likely going to be
big box office hits if there's one thing us comic
book movie fans love more than anything else it's
the anticipation the hiking me those juicy details
things give me those few talking points the future
vehicle on every site that's what we love more
than anything else it's the thing to look forward
to the trickles of what comes next rather than
the actual product yeah so with that in mind if
you're having actual products coming out that
are being big hits and then whatever shows they
have that are also big hits I'm assuming penguin
Joe has to come at some point and then you have
these announcements that alone could generate the
biggest year for 2023. Jonathan oh yeah I mean the
the good thing again about this is that like the
world is their oyster the playing field is Theirs
to gain on and so I feel like if they could show
up at sdcc and then you know come back with the
DC fandom that Rivals that of the first DC fandom
they could have a huge mic drop of a year in 2020
23 and plus it says right there TV movies and
animation and one thing DC is great at I think
most people agree is they're animated movies
and they have some legendary and prolific TV
projects as well so if they could bring all that
stuff together and really you know you've got HBO
caliber shows coming up from this universe that we
already have experience with I feel like that is
a great blend of things to get people excited and
to get this universe if not back on top at least
back in a place where it is commanding the full
respect it deserves yeah that's why they got to
keep canceling shows that nobody likes at death
that's right nobody likes star girl no one has
ever liked star girl no it's really sad what
happened there's a lot of things but there's
a lot of things to be hopeful for too I met a guy
who works on a pretty big WB show and he says the
crew is constantly stressed about the Futures oh I
can't so as much as this is a positive video about
the DCU I am also going to say that I'm aware that
you know and there could be some rocky roads ahead
this is one of many regime changes and it's just
we'll see how this one goes but it seems like
they've picked the right people so I have faith
I want to embrace a tad bit of optimism yeah
and then uh one thing I do want to talk about
that I think should be something that people
ought to get excited about I want to quickly go
over a dramatic report other people have done
videos about it this week already you guys might
have already heard about Dwayne Johnson's thinly
veiled disdain first the Shazam movies and perhaps
even the character what's been coming out the long
story short without going into every single quote
is that there was a deleted scene from Shazam
that has reportedly surfaced that tease Black
Adam showing up in a Shazam Sequel and Dwayne
Johnson wanted that scene to be removed reports
about him having this thinly failed the Zane
disdain the reports about him having a thinly
veiled the stain and also the fact that Peter
saffron produces Shazam so that could create some
potential friction but Dwayne Johnson himself has
come out and said that no it's inevitability
they win will eventually cross over together
and I think there's one thing Dwayne Johnson has
proven with Black Adam whether you love that film
or not he really does care about the fans and
he really does listen to the fans and if he's
gonna work his ass off to make sure Superman
can show up and granted he obviously seems way
more excited at the prospect of a film between
him and Superman than he does between him and
Shazam clearly people want him to go toe-to-toe
with Shazam they want something there to happen
so I don't think Dwayne Johnson the guy who's
notoriously known for listening to his fans
I don't think he's gonna completely ignore his
fans and there has been a rumor a report coming
out that there is a scene or post-credits scene I
don't know if there's a spell or not just a rumor
that they are going to include Black Adam in the
Shazam Fury of the Gods in some way yeah I mean
that would make a lot of sense and yeah given what
The Rock has said on record I feel like it's just
about finessing the project so that they can Co
coalesce together in a way that makes sense and I
feel like the position you're in with Shazam as it
reads to me is partly that you have this character
who is growing and maturing and I feel like at
a third or fourth movie is the more appropriate
time to have him meet a character like Black Adam
and if you look at Black Adam there is a sense of
humor in that movie that is darker but still akin
to what you would see in a Shazam so I feel like
he's well aware that yeah the source material
merits them coming together and I don't think he
has any begrudging quality towards that so I think
it's mostly about taking the right time to do it
rather than rushing it and that seems to be his
whole approach this this entire time a thousand
percent and of course you know we gotta talk about
any minor update from Henry Cavill it's about as
good as Hugh Jackman updating us on Deadpool
3 which is it's happening and I'm excited so
in Henry Cavill he's giving like these quotes out
there lately but there's one in particular there's
an excerpt from one of his very long quotes
because he's just been expressing lately how
excited he is that he's just gonna be back here
he even talked crazy recently about how he hasn't
met James Gunn yet but he's excited to be having
these future ongoing conversations with him about
the future of Superman within the DC Universe but
what he said recently is that but it is humbling
to be the guy who gets to be the custodian of that
character once again and hopefully for many years
to come as long as I do Justice by the character
so if he's putting out words like that it could
just be him putting out wishful thinking or this
hopefulness which is very Superman but putting out
this hopefulness of I want to do more than just
like a couple of films or whatever like I really
want to have a long-term game here with Superman
I think for him to be putting it out there's gotta
at least be some conversations going forward now
about what it is the future of Superman will be
with Henry Cavill and how long can they gestate
that you know what I mean yeah yeah how can they
gracefully grow this into something that can stick
around for a long time and carry that weight and
cultural iconic importance I guess because there
has been such a journey in a road with him and
it's really gratifying and it does seem like
the perfect example of a guy who is completely
suited to the character and they would be foolish
not to make everything they can out of the second
chance that this is because you know people
are gonna people are already petitioning for
him to be reinstated as geralt like people who
love Henry cavill's characters and if he could
really bounce back and really put the definitive
Spirit of Superman stamp on it I feel like that
will alone Bowie the DC Universe for many years
to come uh I think he should come back as girl he
should I feel bad for Liam Emsworth but I'm like
no he's he's my favorite character no no no yeah
I can't imagine not him don't want to watch it
I want to watch it for morbid curiosity I would
like to watch one episode but I yes that's fair
enough I agree alrighty guys well there we are
with the DC Universe what are you most excited
about with the future of this franchise yeah just
wanted to put that out there really quick and
uh share some optimism about it because I'm I'm
starting to fill out all right guys well subscribe
leave a like hey let's send this for the patreon
Lance door Lance it's Thanksgiving time and uh
we're kicking off this month we're acknowledging
our longest most loyal supporters by far you
want you guys want to know how long of a like
how loyal to support this guy is he has not
swayed from the amount pledged that he has
on her patreon page for a total of 57 months
it's almost five years watch me do the math
watch me do the math that's not fun is it that
is like five years yeah I got the patreon for
five years oh that's crazy uh so Lance what are
you gonna do today 365 times five five two uh one
thousand seven hundred twenty five plus seven
months I I don't know how long at first I saw
it I was like 57 months it's like a little over
a year no no wait that's how many weeks though
12 times sixes is uh is no no no oh no
I'm getting what are you talking about
yeah like four years twelve times
five is sixty yeah there you go
that's a long time Lance what are you doing
with your life is something that could have
accrued and been able to generate a real profit
out could have bought a few shares of a modest
stock and watched it grow crypto you'd be
a million oh dude you would yeah and then
you'd lose it and then become a millionaire
again and ride that roller coaster to your
grave but I appreciate you being here
for as long as you have been man it's
uh it's a very very nice support So Lance
I hope you have a wonderful Thanksgiving
and know that we are extremely grateful
for you and your presence thank you buddy